who's the athlete that you are like man
this person was just absolutely dominant
at their Sport and like if you're into
the sport or not you can just sit back
and be like that is amazing so I grew up
my best sport was always swimming when
Phelps won the uh it was 100 fly guy was
full of wall
I understand it's not a swimming so he's
blind he Dives in I mean it's the most
frustrating thing when you have a little
water in your guns but for him to have
the muscle man
count the laps know The Strokes hit a
wall ideally hit the wall perfectly he's
behind you can't see anyone in either
Lane his muscle memory and his actual
like stroke count where he is what he
has to be he's swimming completely blind
and he out touches so it's not even like
he just hits the wall like he actually
does a perfect touch gets up and anybody
if you watch the video he pulls his
goggles off water pours out he turns to
Bob in his coach he goes I couldn't see
all right guys bang bang I'm here with
John uh you wrote a book that ranks
presidents based on their athleticism
was just the premise of that alone is
absolutely absurd and awesome where did
that idea come from and who is the most
athletic president in history and who is
the least athletic president awesome yes
a good place to start so I that book
came from an article I used to write for
muscle and fitness magazine for a long
time for seven or eight years they did
all their big cover stories WWE guys UFC
guys football players anybody who was
jacked enough to kind of fit that mold
and um I hijacked an issue during 2012
and you'll love this I wanted to do like
a athletic political issue but not
politics basically like politicians but
no politicians like Just Sports and
athletes so I none of it happened by the
way but I mocked it up with a couple
guys it was called the big cover line
picture of Big Jack dude was red white
and huge
the uh the taglines were um like freedom
of the bench press and like instead of
Metal of Honor metal is m-e-t-t-l-e like
tough guy melavon all this whole thing I
mocked it up and the the center piece of
the whole thing was this article that I
did ranking the athletic presidents
um we basically did the article me and a
couple of my writers who were younger
like this would be so awesome like
everybody's gonna love it it's gonna be
like a buzzy thing a little before
Twitter but like people are gonna talk
about it
gets to New York we were in La the the
big Publishers look at it and are like
yeah no we're not putting red white and
huge like we're not gonna talk about
politics even even like tangentially
about their muscular stuff like we're
out so the only thing they kept was this
top 10 piece and they cut it down like
like hurt my soul as a writer anyway
right like you just believe in this idea
and there was no real automatic feedback
so I was gonna get like emails later and
they cut everything out the only thing I
had left was the top 10 ranked and they
gave me like 80 words to talk about like
why Abraham Lincoln was a street fighter
and you know Gerald Ford actually played
football all that so that comes out
people love it they're writing
handwritten emails like this is really
funny it was great I start to pitch a
book idea and nobody like I don't know
no one wants it I'm pitching it to New
York I'm pitching it to LMP all the
Publishers I had a loose like agent this
is 15 years ago no one wants a 2012 so
10 years ago and I decide do some
research I'm gonna put this [__] book
out my eye but like you're gonna talk
about this stuff I'm gonna put this I
already did like other books but like
the technology had gotten to the point
where you could I first saw mad at
magazine so I have people who can design
the book I have people who can edit the
book I have people who can lay the book
out I can write the thing like I just
need a printer and Ingram just came out
of this thing called ingramspark at the
time and Kendall had a it was called
like Kindle Direct publishing or
CreateSpace I think then and I was like
I'm gonna print like 50 and I'm like
it's not going to cost me much and if I
sell 100 books like we'll see what
happens so I get into it and it's like
man there's a lot of presidents a lot of
them have like done nothing but a lot
have done a ton in the Sports World so
then I realized the only way this is
legitimate is if I take myself out of it
and I come up with like an objective
ranking system like if I like Mel Kuiper
the [__] out of this and I call it
Jackson chief
so I come up with like five categories
like what they did in athletics before
they were president what they did in
athletics during how strong were they
overall as a person how tough were they
um and then what was their legacy
athletically and I came up with a one
through ten scale and I'm like interview
like researching Rutherford B Hayes and
calling like the calvage Coolidge
Library like did he really have these
dumbbells and all this stuff and so yeah
so that was that was how that book came
out and it was nuts when people read it
today what is their take is it like hey
you should just keep updating it with
each new president that's the beauty of
it so from a business standpoint every
four years I have a new book I added I
added Trump when he came in I have to
wait so judge he was like in the 20s so
people don't know as much as people
can't stand him like he was actually a
very good high school athlete he was
looked at in baseball he threw in like
the high 80s played on the football team
and then he had a weird thing like after
after all it was over he has this
ridiculous notion of like conserving
energy like he doesn't it's in there
like he he doesn't exercise Because he
believes you only have so much energy
in your life so he looks obviously not
like someone who exercises so that is an
insane Theory it's a quote there's a
quote in the book where he's like I you
know I just all the people I know who
exercise are getting new hips and I
don't want that you only have so many
heartbeats and I want to waste that
exercise you look like him and you walk
around like him and that's yeah that's
what happens when you do that but for a
brief time he's decent athlete no
exercise in office no focus on activity
so he was in the
he's a big like overweight kind of guy
not in the Taft sense or even the
Clinton sense but he was up there
um but the beauty of this story is so I
write the book
and I have enough people through the
magazine world that I can get it out
there he gets picked up the New York
Post
New York Post friend of mine Kirsten
Fleming I'll give her credit forever was
like this is a really cool idea I want
to interview about how'd you come up
with this I tell the same version of
this story uh she reads it gets picked
up a bunch of places in the post I get a
call like driving home to like get my
kid to soccer it's CBS This Morning
somehow got my number from her can you
fly here tomorrow to do a live show on
CBS This Morning and I'm like yeah so I
call my wife and I'm like hey we got to
figure this out like she's like what are
you doing I'm flying in New York live in
Texas at the time I'm like they're gonna
put me like live to talk about this
goofy book that because it was in
election season I timed it right I'm not
an idiot like it's going to come out
during the primaries everything or
during the election and so they fly me
up and all of a sudden I'm sitting there
New York City CBS you know Anthony Mason
and like the book cover is up there the
Green Room has a copy of it like people
are asking me to sign it and I'm like
four months ago like not a single
publisher on Earth I got I got 40
rejection letters No One's Gonna read
this no one cares it's a listicle it's
something in BuzzFeed I sold like 900
books by the time I flew home and and so
that was where the idea came from and
that was sort of the cool feel good
story of like bet on yourself and ever
it still sells a couple hundred books a
year I don't do much with it and every
four years I put it out so I have to
wait till Biden's done because a portion
of the rankings is on uh how they were
fit in office like Reagan was Notorious
like he did circuit training he did
Nautilus stuff he rode his horse like he
was into it Obama like always like
exercising playing Hoops like he had a
nice gym that is like probably the
coolest White House Gym they had
um all the way ranking down to other
guys who didn't do anything but so once
up once Biden's out I can add another
one but every four years I'll just keep
updating it and it'll just keep selling
with Biden uh he rides his bicycle I
know he does that uh is that considered
like strenuous activity or not
I put in the front like this is a book
for like actual athletes I'm not gonna
be like oh you know Harry Truman walked
you know two miles a day 2.2 miles a day
at a certain Pace every day like okay
but who cares yeah like John Quincy
Adams swam two miles in the Potomac in
the winter nude I give that a lot of
credit like that was badass right like
he was cold plunging before and swimming
like there's stories of him going like
two miles like going off course like his
staff I can't find him like they're
running along the edge with his clothes
like you gotta come out you gotta come
out can you imagine today the New York
Post being like the president is naked
in the Potomac swimming he's a great one
of my favorite quotes from the whole
book so Taft big guy like he gets hit a
lot always like knocked out of the
fattest president but you know what like
he worked really hard he's a wrestler in
high school he tried really hard to stay
in shape he hired Fitness people he just
was big dude as he got older it was
really hard to keep the weight off so he
also was a big like swimmer type because
it was easy on his joints so he goes to
the ocean I think he was in like Cape
Cod or something on like a president's
Retreat and he starts waiting out the
big guy who got stuck in the bathtub and
then he's about to go in a bunch of his
staff are going to go and they go wait
president's using the ocean
there's no room for anybody else that is
absurd it's like the best staff joke
ever about the president
all right so you wrote another book
you've written a lot of books but
there's a couple I want to specifically
talk about uh 1996 is the best sports
year of all time yes why all right so I
wanted to write that book since I was a
kid it's 96th year I graduated high
school and my kids are now 9 and 11 my
son is really into sports my daughter
not so much but like everything we talk
about now uh if you think about it like
the whole world changed in 96 the whole
sport World changed at 96. so I
originally had the idea called like
decade of icons I was gonna focus it on
all the 90s and then my Asian and I were
kicking it around and he was like you
know these yearbooks of like the year
and I was like yeah let's do I'm gonna
do a biography of a sports here not that
it's like never been done but no one's
really tackled it that way it's always
like a year in review or a look back but
I was like I'm gonna do a biography as
if the year was a person so if you think
about it just from a from a sports
perspective and actually I think I
talked to your brother Joe about it like
on an email chain once like so before in
1995 I'm in high school nobody cares
about tiger he's just an amateur person
the few people outside of golf ever
heard of uh Alan Iverson is in high
school I mean I was in college
Georgetown he has a nurse Madness but
like that's the first time he shows up
he's not a household named nothing
Kobe's nobody the high school kid that's
supposed to be good at basketball
outside of people who follow it no one
can you circuit or whatever Jackson
Orlando so there was no Kobe and Shaq
right there okay you've got know the
rock no stone cold both of them were
screwing around just hadn't gone on to
uh Sports yet no major league soccer no
WNBA you've got Mike Tyson still in jail
hasn't come back yet so like when you
look back at now everybody you can't
talk about sports every athlete now I've
interviewed done I've done books with
them they look back who are your icons
Kobe Iverson tiger Shaq the Kobe Lakers
like MLS now soccer matters you know
WNBA is now huge people actually follow
it before in 1995 none of these
conversations happened yeah they didn't
even matter so if you look at like it's
like a line of demarcation like before
96 none of that happened and then after
and then the second part of it is if you
look at the people who were huge in 96
right so you've got the Cowboys win
their third Super Bowl like look at that
team right like Michael Irvin's still on
TV Dion as big popular wise probably as
ever Aikman the number one announcer
these guys have been on TV on Sundays
for like 25 26 years right commercials
now now he's doing Geico with Nick Saban
he was doing like dominoes with uh David
Robinson like these guys have not left
they haven't left the scene tiger is as
influential as ever and so if you look
back like there's this line everything I
talked about in high school was cool but
from then on it's all these new people
who came into existence in the sports
kind of universe in 1996. I remember
Alan Iverson he was like literally my
one of my childhood like uh heroes in
sports right and um I remember as he was
becoming more popular in the NBA uh I
was in Middle School around like the
late 90s and uh we convinced our coach
who had zero power I'm pretty sure he
was a volunteer to mandate which really
meant we were mandated that all of the
team got the uh first Allen Iverson
shoes I think they were the uh the
answers that
um uh they had a little zip up because I
think those came out before the
questions the questions came out later
if I remember correctly and so remember
there's like 12 to 15 white kids in a
random you know Middle School in the
middle of North Carolina was a huge
basketball like also yeah and we all get
these out on Iverson shoes and I
remember uh parents being like who's
Alan Iverson right because I mean he's
like really just starting to become
popular
and then they go and they look and
they're like
I don't know if we're into like the
whole team wearing the Islanders right
and he had the armband like he was
starting to put it all together and uh
then I remember as our parents fought it
yeah we became more obsessed he got on
the cover of Slam Magazine and like as
soon as all that hit it was like Allen
Iverson cannot be [__] with yeah and
then of course practice and then it like
exploded and our parents were like what
is going on who is this guy why are our
kids always trying to watch sports
center every single night to see who we
crossed up yeah like it just snowballed
into this huge thing and it's like hey
you don't remember like I definitely
don't remember really before that like
that is like a seminal moment for me of
his like big explosion onto the scene
and he changed how basketball really got
played yeah because we were so I'm a
little older than you and it was like
Bird magic like you know all those guys
Michael like when you're watching the 92
Olympic dream team was like the biggest
thing ever and like you're moving on
those guys they're all retiring then you
know obviously Jordan 19 798 like still
big but from an influential state
standpoint like those guys were clearly
at some point moving on yep and then you
have like Iverson and the beauty of
Iverson is like he came almost out of
nowhere he was your size I mean I I
covered him a bunch when I went you know
for hoopsies some other places like he
was six foot he was 160 pounds and he
was in this land of giants it had just
this fight in him and you didn't have to
be from anywhere to just watch him and
be like this guy is different and he's
awesome and then some of the stories
like that I that I had to uncover for 96
are incredible because so he was a Nike
guy Nike high school John Thompson's
georgetown's Nike Thompson is on the
board of Nike everybody's like he's
going Nike
Reebok is like you go to Nike
Jordan signs Iverson you go to Nike it's
like oh you know maybe the penny will
maybe Penny will give a little push to
Iverson in the little Penny commercials
Iverson's like no [__] way I want my
shoe he goes there and they come up with
this huge campaign I can't remember the
name of the two guys but they were
watching Mark Madness and they're like
we need him we're basically going to say
to our guys uh we're going to put our
entire marketing Budget on this guy
basically what Nike did with Jordan way
back when and and we're gonna give we
want him to be him we don't want to
polish him into Nike or interview but we
want to make Reebok what he wants and
Iverson was like that that's who I get
behind that and get behind that and he
comes out he's got he's in you know
inputting designing the shoes they let
him be who he wanted to be and it was
like the most brilliant sneaker decision
you could ever make from a company
perspective I um I always say that the
questions still to this day I think are
the best shoes ever made yeah 96 was
cool because you still had Jordans yeah
his shoe comes out Shaq had the hypnosis
like which which he looked like you know
it was weird and then the pennies were
cool and Pippin had his own shoe and
like some of these shoes that came out
then were great but but there was no
there was no answer to the Jordan it was
like the Jordans in general there was
nothing as cool there were shoes that
were like there are people like Penny
Shaq whatever but there was no athlete
who you were like I'm gonna wrap these
shoes because I think he can stand up
and be as cool as Jordan and that's what
that's why Iverson meant so from 96 it's
like how do you even talk about
basketball in 2023 without Kobe and
Iverson because every athlete you talk
about LeBron pickham Kevin Durant their
favorite athlete was either 100 yeah the
other uh big moment I remember uh where
an athlete kind of broke through uh with
a bunch of my friends was uh Carmelo
Anthony in uh March Madness when he and
Syracuse went on the huge run yeah and
everyone was just like dude who is this
guy and it was the same type of
ingredients then right it was like it
was a kid who just like obviously size
wise he was different but it's just like
this kid is not gonna uh quit and he's
just tough as [__] yeah and I think that
there was something about that entire
like kind of mid 90s to like early 2000s
where kids who that were like maybe
College down to like Middle School
school and if you're into basketball you
were just like things are changing yeah
and these guys are like the leaders of
this new wave yeah you had you know
there was it was almost they had that
passing the torch it skipped over
because it's really not Jordan to Kobe
and all these guys like there was an
error in the middle of like Marbury yes
Garnett Chris Webber and some of these
guys that were they were awesome but
they didn't you know McGrady like they
didn't capture imagination Vince did
Vince did because of the dunks and that
was sick but like he never had the you
know the playoff stuff he never made a
finals he kind of never pushed over
there over that hump of being like the
cultural icon yeah uh but it was Iverson
and it was Kobe and it's an unbelievable
thing to think about like and you're
sitting in high school it's like that
conversation of who's who's Alan who
like he plays for where Georgetown he
played football somewhere in high school
like Kobe like who the the you know the
Hornets want him or the Lakers are going
to get him like okay what a bust another
High School guy nobody cares about and
now it's changed completely forever all
right so LeBron played football in high
school I think he broke his finger or
something so he stopped playing but his
team either won the state championship
or like they're like good yeah and
obviously if you've got a 6A dude run
down the sideline yeah it's pretty hard
not to be good uh Alan Iverson was a
quarterback in Virginia Virginia uh he
claims he was better at football than he
was at basketball I have a great story
okay he gets the Georgetown he gets in a
lot he I'm sorry people say he got in
some trouble he got in a fight at a
bowling alley and there was like legit
violence not shooting really like real
fight yeah real fight they were throwing
chairs unfortunately you know back then
the stuff like only the white kids got
in trouble all the black kids got
arrested especially Iverson like ruining
his future
um at the time uh and it's cool how some
of my books intersect like I did a
biography on Charlie Ward they were
looking at him as the next Charlie were
because he was an incredible quarterback
great arm elusive all the same stuff
Charlie could do it was a couple years
after Charlie had just won the Heisman
and also taken his basketball team to
the elite eight so they're like you can
build a college offense around in
Florida State looked at him a bunch of
schools looked at him he gets in trouble
no one's looking at him in like the
greatest Mom move of all time iris's mom
drives up to Georgetown talks to John
Thompson and is like help my son like he
has he cannot this can't ruin his life
Thompson takes him brings him up like
you will listen every goddamn word I say
and I will I will bet on you and you
will just listen to me Iverson says
great so the first year unbelievable
second year Iverson's like he's becoming
who he is a little bit of a star decides
to roll in a Big John's office and test
his weight and says I want to play
football he says get your ass out of
here
I brought you here to play basketball
and that's a great story and it's true
and so Iverson was that good he was
being looked at for both Sports when I
think of uh his story and then you
compare him to Charlie Ward uh I don't
actually think most people would think
of those two as uh the comparison
because then it was the comparison now I
think it's Dion and Charlie Ward who's
more athletic so this is I get when the
book came out this was like the number
one question like it's like all right Bo
Jackson Dion Sanders and Charlie are the
only ones to have so this is what this
is my this is my answer and I think this
is the way I've thought about it I
promise you like way more than anybody
else all right so Bo Jackson if you've
read Jeff perlman's books it's
incredible just came out like
he was born a physical freak and he used
that to be like a mythological character
in football and baseball and track
actually also he was Unstoppable he
could jump over five foot fences 500
foot home runs like there's stories in
there and the research he did is
incredible like he was an Unstoppable
Force he could get out on anybody he was
a singular Talent he handed in the ball
he ran put him at bat he hit Dion same
thing like fastest could be returning
punts the team didn't rely on him the
quarterback got him the ball you know in
football in baseball pitcher pitching
the ball Charlie Charlie was the
quarterback in point guard he wasn't
just some guy who was getting by on
speed although he had world-class speed
and he wasn't just some guy getting off
by on like athletic ability although you
know his father was an exceptional High
School athlete he clearly had the jeans
for it but he was a brilliant athletic
mind and he had to run the offense every
play went through him shift gears after
football and then go play basketball and
take that Team Elite eight and he plays
the start you know starting finals like
NBA point guard so to me the best team
athlete the best leader is Charles the
award obviously Beau is probably like in
a decathlon Dion and bow might be better
yeah but if you're asking me I think
Charlie is the most impressive what
about somebody like a Myron role so
Myron role uh for those who don't know I
think he played at fourth state uh I
don't think they won uh they won bowl
games I don't think they won a national
championship right and then he got a
road scholarship yeah and if I remember
correctly there's like some controversy
because it was like is he gonna go take
the scholarship and go uh and do that or
is he gonna go to the NFL and he chose
to go do the scholarship uh and he
wanted to become a doctor and I think
that he's actually a neural surgeon now
yeah I think he's become a neurosurgeon
and so like when you look at somebody
like that that's not two sports but like
that may be harder like yeah Paul and
basketball is being on Florida State's
football team winning bowl games and
also like becoming a neurosurgeon yeah
the classwork is crazy and one of the
themes of all these guys that I end up
talking to is like at some point the the
work needs to be gone the film room has
to get done like especially if you're a
quarterback especially your point guard
even in high school people some of these
guys who are playing all these sports
are shifting back and forth constantly
and school right and so the mental
agility I think and that's again why I
put Charlie a little a little ahead in
terms of an overall picture of like
running an offense on both of those yeah
like he jumps into college basketball at
like January and like he's playing
against guys who all they do are are you
know five star recruits at McDonald's
all Americans from North Carolina you
know NC State like the best schools in
the country Duke and he just came off
winning the Heisman national
championship and within a month they are
a well-oiled machine okay he had a Sam
Cassell on his team yeah Edwards he had
some players so it wasn't like he had no
one there but uh but he's a point guard
immediately comes in and like picks up
the stride Elite eight so it's like when
I think about being able to do that and
then the same thing the flip side he
Well everybody's doing Spring football
and spring practices he's in the March
Madness and then he's like shifting
gears back into like running the offense
for Bobby Bowden so to me I put that
just as like a little bit of I don't
know how you want to measure it but I
put that as just a little Notch above so
in high school I played football
basketball and baseball and I had
obviously friends who just played
football friends who just played
basketball yeah uh in college I played
football uh and we at one point played
uh unofficially some of the basketball
players in basketball yeah uh didn't go
so hot for them
it just you know there's a physicality
especially in the middle of football
season yes
um but one of the debates all throughout
high school and into college that we
would have over and over again is it
easier for a football player to go play
in the NBA or is it easier for an NBA
player to go play in the NFL which one
do you think so I would say that um from
a sheer like physical standpoint
the NBA the guys don't stop moving like
if you watch I've done the articles on
like training for the combine all this
stuff the physicality NFL is unmatched
but like you do your 20 second 10 second
route or you're running back new thing
you may be off the field maybe not
you're maybe back on you're maybe not
you don't have that in the NBA and a lot
of the guys pick probably which one
they're going to be absolutely best at
but from a conditioning standpoint in
game I think it might be harder for some
of the especially like tight end Maybe
by position it's probably a better way
to do it but I think this is the this is
part of the debate right is okay the NBA
player like what are they going to do
they can't be the quarterback most of
them are like I'll be a receiver or
tight end and then right like that's
pretty much the only two options on
offense uh and then on defense they're
like oh you know maybe uh I'd be like a
a d end or something all right I covered
the summer league in 2001 or two when
there was a um they were doing like
there was an NFL strike okay Tony
Gonzalez who played basketball with uh
Jason Kidd right yeah man with Jason
Kidd and then he goes in the you know
obviously NFL is really good
um I I watched him in the summer he
played for the heat if he was he was
saying if the NFL wasn't gonna come back
he's gonna pay for the Heat
if you look at him on a football field
he's like this Unstoppable dominant
jacked Force he's just a dude on the
basketball court he's five inches
shorter than Amari Stoudemire who's
there the other power forwards karon
Butler looks like he looks like he's his
big brother hey how you doing like Tony
like that's a big deal these NFL guys
especially these running back they can't
play they're too small yeah some of them
uh but I would say like from a direct
comp having watched him again he was
only he was coming off the NFL the NBA
if he's a lead athlete I mean he was a
bench player like trying to make it uh
and then so I'm not knocking him like
obviously hall of fame or football and
amazing that he could do all that but if
we're looking for maybe an Apples to
Apples comp like size wise and speed
wise he wasn't with those guys and that
might be might be the difference you
wrote a book about Nate Robinson
speaking of size uh and I think it's
called heart over height yes if I
remember correctly
um
is his legacy ruined after Jake Paul
knocked him out it sucks because he's
one of my favorite athletes ever he's
the man in terms of the basketball if
you leave if you leave I blame
I've texted him about like I blame his
trainers
[Laughter]
the point still is one of the fastest he
should have not got hit for five rounds
and that's all I don't know what their
plan was but if I were by I've covered a
ton of boxing I have interview boxers I
like boxing you like MMA boxing like
nobody can touch him speed wise he
should have just spun around and worn
him out maybe you know just lasted the
last thing I think he probably would
have wanted to do is what happened and
just get stone cold knocked out in front
of millions and millions of people but
it hurts uh as someone who's a friend of
his now because this kind of happens
when you do these books with these guys
you just get invested in their lives you
start to know them and their wives and
their kids and like you root for them
um again when I do when you do like a
co-author thing you're kind of putting
your journalism hat away so if I did
like a biography on it be a little
different because you're really coming
at it from all angles but
um Nate was the first guy to give me
like a shot to like co-write a book with
him so always be grateful to him for
that and he's awesome we've had fun but
for for everyone listen who doesn't kind
of know in a 30 second story like Nate
Robinson
um Seattle Rainier Beach comes up he's
five seven five eight even as like a
sophomore he's a phenomenon football and
basketball and then at 5'8 he is the Mr
basketball and Mr Football in the state
of Washington now just he's five eight
and if High School is probably five
seven ish in a legit I mean I've stood
next to him I'm a tower over the guy he
could have played track like ran track
he got recruited for Steve Carroll's USC
team Reggie Bush Lendale white like did
his visit he could have gone to Arizona
could have gone to Michigan I looked at
everywhere for football got looked at at
a ton of places for basketball what
positions did he play he played point
guard and he was a corner okay he was a
ridiculous power like if you have time
YouTube like Nate Robinson High School
highlights like just every punt was like
touchdown touchdown touchdown kick
touchdown like pick everybody off and he
decided he wanted to stay home
Washington he's like a big like he loves
his hometown like he goes stays home in
Washington freshman year plays both
Sports has like a huge interception in
the Washington State game everybody's
like you you're going pro like you're
gonna go to the NFL and he's like I just
I want to play basketball and they're
like you're nuts like you're you're five
eight and he's like this is what I want
to do so after his sophomore year he
quits focusing on fastball first round
draft pick you know averages 16 17 18
points for the Knicks three dunk
contests only got a win three Dunk
Contest so like to me that is his legacy
like an unbelievable phenomenal one of
the best athletes we've had and it sucks
at like a generation of people are like
Nate the guy who got punched in the face
and by the YouTuber so uh I I have a
controversy about the dunk contest yeah
I don't think that they should have uh
various Heights participate because it
doesn't look the same when a guy who's 6
10 does a windmill and then Nate
Robinson does a windmill and like dude
that guy jumped higher you're like no he
just had to go higher
I know yeah I mean that's like they have
an advantage if they can dunk if you're
shorter it just looks way cooler than a
guy who kind of doesn't even look like
he's trying he does white tried the
12-foot one and it just still didn't
look cool it was like you're so big and
and it's not moving and yeah it is it is
interesting because like you know Spud
Webb won against Dominique and like if
you watch those old 85 86 Dunk Contest
Dominique was like an artist I mean the
moves he did the movement of the ball if
you slow him down like a full 360 like
eight foot radius dunk but then Spud
would do like a a 360 and you're like
whoa like
get off the ground
so nay was a power dunker too which was
cool like in-game in traffic dunker
which was great
um but I hear your point like it always
looks more pleasing uh you know he he
dunked over Dwight Howard which is
really cool and he was like really
creative he had the green crypto Nate
shoes to go over Dwight Howard in a
Superman costume and Dwight was a pretty
good sport I don't know if the 90s
athletes would have been like yeah we're
competing sure dunk over me that'll be
great I do think that there's a little
bit of a change there yeah I don't think
the guys had much coronary there
camaraderie there but you know why has
LeBron never done a dunk contest
I think it's like if you look at the
legacy of the guys he who he's in line
with you know Jordan did it one amazing
Kobe did it once even though he wore his
little warm up in one like you do it
once I think LeBron's yeah there's
Undisputed whatever for third fourth
he's not I don't think he's better than
Jordan whatever who cares about that
argument but he's in the top whatever
two three of all time but he should have
done it once
a rookie yeah I think no one would have
beat him no no he would have won they
make you they make sure they would have
made sure he won and he had the ability
I mean the dude could jump he could
touch the top of the backboard like he
should have just done it that's all I'm
not I'm saying the punk only because
like I don't know who got in his ear if
like you're too cool for this especially
at like 19. yeah but he should have done
it once and won it and then he's like a
two cool thing or was he scared of like
if you go up there and you embarrass
yourself because you're trying too hard
I can't imagine him being scared he's
the ultimate like physical specimen like
his first game when he did that dunking
it was against Sacramento or whatever
like he had been owning dudes his age
since he was like 12. like I can't
imagine fear would have come in I think
somebody was like Hey you know if you
don't win he would have won and I think
he had all the dunks to win I just I
don't know it's one of those when he was
in high school yeah it like I don't
remember I was probably too young when
Kobe was in a senior year like some of
the I watched the videos now but
LeBron in high school was just like not
fair no like just literally watching him
and they'd be like on National
Television like oh there's like a game
right and you can watch and you're like
dude they got a 5A white kid Garden
LeBron and LeBron literally is toying
with this Catholic Prep School literally
just rotated in and this guy is like
trying right because he's like hey I'm
on I'm on TV I can't let Lebron dunk on
me and then there you go just literally
dunks on the whole team at once and they
were cool because like I mean No One's
Gonna build like a uniform and a look
for a team around me or you but it was
like do you like these green jerseys oh
we can get different oh yeah like them
big and baggy now with no sleeves we'll
do that for like he had the cool shoes
The Chosen One cover like if you think
the most amazing thing to me about
LeBron is
all the hype
everything now if me or you I would have
been the biggest [__] I probably
would have done 50 things in my 20s that
I'd be embarrassed about now or like
been written off we probably did do this
the fact that like he has all of that
and like good dad good you know what I
mean like good husband like smart and
business gives back to the community no
real like trouble no fights like it's
pretty incredible like that from a from
a character perspective uh that he never
went off the rails I was like I'm a 25
year old million everybody loves me like
it never happened the two biggest kind
I've always said this right it's like
he's the he's probably the one person
with the most hype that lived up to it
and I would argue he probably surpassed
it even though he had chosen one and all
the stuff but uh if you think of other
people who were like similar vain uh
Sebastian Telfair remember when he was
coming out and like and everyone was
like this is the next one I'm gonna sell
this fan like we had him I was like
we're gonna get the coolest like he and
it just doesn't happen it didn't happen
yeah and then uh in football there was a
kid um Tavon Austin you ever hear this
kid yeah so uh him and there was a kid
in Florida I forget his name
um but uh Noel Devine I think was his
name uh and so both of these guys had
highlight tapes and went like there's
like the first viral like high school
football highlight tapes and uh if the
kid's name is Noel Divine that I'm
thinking of
it's like the State of Florida not a
tackle like literally he would like run
into a pile it'd be like 15 Defenders
right you're like there's only 11 on the
field like no I think there's 15. it
comes that just pops out the other end
and so just I remember being in like
high school costumes like what the [__]
is this kid doing and then uh Austin uh
his highlight tape the first five
minutes is him literally dancing on the
field of music it's awesome like you're
just like you have to be good right like
if you put on your highlight tape just
you warming up dancing to music you have
to go to a top D1 school because if any
coach watched all of that like they're
like okay I gotta have the kid right and
they all fizzle out they don't make it
it's hard I mean it's really hard
especially when I mean now it's even
harder but I mean you're putting LeBron
on the cover of Sports illustrator
you've got like you've got cautionary
tales of guys who you know that happens
to and you never hear from him again I
mean Kwame Brown you never hear from
again like even if they're not that
level of hype
um and just it's what it's his 20 20th
year like it's insane that he's still
where he is and he's going to end up
being the greatest I mean the guys he's
compared to didn't come out like that
they were high draft picks or whatever
but they weren't the anointed as like
the greatest basketball player of all
time or whatever it was in their Sport
and then like when you watch them
dominate other sports the greatest what
if I ever see is um so in uh in a high
school West Virginia Randy Moss was like
a basketball player like a point four
point guard I mean sorry power forward
and J Will was his point guard and then
in football Jason Williams was the
quarterback and he was the wide receiver
like if you could have somehow let both
of them do both like obviously better
basketball football whichever one like
different sports but like can you
imagine if they like somehow like
YouTuber like can you have five years to
both go play football on the same team
in the NFL or college like or college
and then you can both actually go play
basketball together Randy Moss was an
unbelievable basketball player greatest
team of all time arguably but like I
would love I love those stories of like
the the what ifs of who could have been
and what could have happened if they
just stuck with a different sport Randy
Moss literally was so good that most
became like
like literally became a verb like you
are very good and then also I remember
uh there was a a song that came out when
I was in college uh some DJ had like
remixed it and uh they took remember his
interview where he was getting in his uh
car and he was like Straight Cash homie
oh yeah right and they remixed the whole
thing and they would just play it and he
and he literally you're just like this
guy is amazing at uh at football
um but it's it's cool to hear how good
he was at basketball as well hey guys
what's going on I hope that you're
enjoying this conversation but I wanted
to interrupt for a quick second and tell
you about a brand new conference that
I'm hosting on March 4th at the Miami
Beach Convention Center the event is
called lyceum Miami and tickets are
completely free for anyone who wants to
come I'm bringing together many of the
most popular guests from the podcast
over the last couple of years some of
the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek Rama
Swami from strive asset management or
Delian and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceumiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there all right
let's get back into this conversation
yeah I love those stories like the when
I when I ever do books on a lot of these
guys I always look for that other what
was that other thing you know Vince
Carter Vince Carter was an All-American
it could have been an All-American
volleyball player he was all state he
was I mean if you think about it
volleyball volleyball can you imagine
that guy you're just some dude who only
plays volleyball with your nice little
like 24 inch vertical and you're you
know you're 6'2 jumping up and Mitch
Carter vid sanity future like ridiculous
dunker over everybody she comes like 42
inches and puts the ball in your face
right and they're like he's gonna go to
the Olympics like he could be the future
of American volleyball and he's like
yeah I'm not doing that he's like I'm
gonna go and play but I'll play
volleyball in the spring because we have
a volleyball team and like who knows
he's never going to do it he goes on the
beach like Chase Budinger who was in the
dunk contest went and played I used to
see him I lived in La like he played on
the AVP tour like it translated over him
he was really good but like those little
glimpses of like what if Vince was like
I just want to be the greatest
volleyball player that has ever played
volleyball I want to be known as The
Babe Ruth volleyball the Michael Jordan
volleyball that is gonna be what I'm
gonna do be crazy
but like would anyone know who he is nah
that's why I do it like I have a UNC or
volleyball like yeah I I don't uh I'm
not even gonna apologize for this but I
don't think I could actually name a
single volleyball player well I lived
out there so I was into it is like the
guy yeah um dollhauser and Rogers and
then honestly the most famous is Misty
May carry you know Carrie Wallace or the
probably if you ask anybody just
volleyball what do they still play no
right or yeah maybe Kerry Walsh might I
don't know if she's retired yet but they
played I mean for yeah funny one of the
coolest uh in-person events I've ever
seen it's very small packed house on the
beach in Hermosa Beach the CB the uh the
the AVP would allow anybody to go they
couldn't California you're not allowed
to at least if you couldn't charge
tickets on Sand because it was public so
they would build the stadium and you'd
have to just anybody could show him walk
on and Kerry Walsh and Misty May were
about to beat the the record I don't
remember who it was for the most wins by
a doubles team
and it was a place like this these are
die hard like 1200 that's it like die
hard in the wool volleyball fan beach
volleyball fans who grew up watching
these guys and it was nuts and I
remember thinking like man if you just
get to the thing that you are supposed
to be doing yeah fans didn't get
acknowledged it like obviously they got
the Olympics and all that but it was one
of like the coolest just moments to see
for them it was like you know like cow
rook and breaking Lou Gehrig's record it
was huge and for that crowd it was
amazing did uh uh Ripken they pull the
lights was that did they pull the lights
you ever heard a story no so I'm pretty
sure uh no I'm sorry is it Cal Ripken or
Lou Gehrig and maybe there's a story
about both of them but uh one of them I
thought it was Cal Ripken uh he was uh
on his way to the stadium or something
happened and he was going to miss a game
and supposedly uh the lights on the
stadium didn't work same day uh
interesting yeah I heard there was a few
of those with him a couple one at bat
type deals and uh and things like that
to me that record I was in the in like
you know that was probably when I still
really followed baseball yeah yeah it's
it's awesome but
the last few years he wasn't doing it it
was really just like and he was still he
was an amazing athlete he also could
play basketball in other sports but like
kind of just let me get my at bats like
I'm not not batting 340 anymore here let
me just get let me just get through this
record and everybody can you know clap
and be excited about it who's the
athlete that you are like man this
person was just absolutely dominant at
their Sport and like if you're into the
sport or not you can just sit back and
be like that is amazing so I grew up my
best sport was always swimming and I
have an appreciation for Michael Phelps
that I can't have another Sports I'm
below average at basketball I can play
one-on-one I play all the time but like
I was not I didn't even make my high
school team I was all County Allstate
swimmers was the only sport I was really
good at I played football punted you
know full back like [__] whatever
but I was good at swimming I understood
what it would take to be like a good
swimmer every fullback is like [__] this
guy yeah yeah it's like Mike all Scott
is like dude get out of here yeah every
single mother like this guy like why why
you know I my thing was you talk about
funny jokes for for being like an
African think about playing through
Sports I was a really good swimmer and I
got on like our high school story and
this is a funny thing is like so it's
all these like nerdy summers are nerds
like they're all oh they can't talk and
I'm coming from football I have to lose
20 pounds like I'm on this thing High
School sports talk with this guy Jimmy
Cavallo and he's like John uh I'm 19
you're 18 like this cocky just douchebag
and he's like John you came from
football it looks like you want to you
know is there anyone else that you know
of on your team or in the county who who
goes from football into swimming and it
has a success and I was like no I don't
think anybody can do that
and I like dead dead stare like two shot
into the camera and I get home and my
message machine is you know I'm gonna
have cell phones like just hey [__]
oh you're the only like my friends just
we are going to use this for the rest of
your life like who the hell like staring
into the camera like like I'm a WWE like
throwing down the gauntlet like yeah you
try to punt and do butterfly like yeah
nobody can do that so so that is uh my
little swimming moment but Phelps
when Phelps won the uh I believe it was
100 fly goggles full of water
I understand it's all swimming and
swimming he's blind he Dives in I mean
it's the most frustrating thing when you
have a little water in your goggles but
for him to have the muscle memory just
count the laps know The Strokes hit a
wall ideally hit the wall perfectly he's
behind he can't see anyone in either
Lane his muscle memory and his actual
like stroke count where he is what he
has to be he's swimming completely blind
and he out touches so it's not even like
he just hits the wall like he actually
does a perfect touch gets up and anybody
if you watch the video he pulls his
goggles off water pours out he turns the
Bob in his coach and goes I couldn't see
dude I don't care what sport you're in
what you do if you just try to swim one
lap with goggles full and just I just
say touch the wall you couldn't do it
let alone be the rest of the best in the
world at that event so for me it's
Michael Phelps so when he did that
specific race he went down touched the
wall and came back in touch and it was
over yeah so down and back basically and
touch policies it's really a turn and
touch the wall and he did it all with
one butterfly not like even we can kind
of maybe like he couldn't
right you think you have goggles that
works it never happens I mean everybody
who's
swailed and they're not especially then
like the Olympics you've got your cap
goggles in the cap over the goggles like
to triple check like your doubles triple
sealed
I don't know how it happened but the
panic mode of the Olympics like oh [__]
I just I can't see and then like Focus
calm down and just swim your race that
you've sworn four billion times in
practice by math in your head
it's the most insane I think it's the
most is it better to swim with the with
the water in there or just take them off
I think you take them off if you could
because at least when you're up you can
kind of gauge where you are I mean I
mean I have contact so I'm screwed
either way yeah but like assuming I
can't even swim down
yeah you can see but like any swimmer
listening now is like yeah that you know
you look at all the other Feats and
there's a million things I mean the flu
game and all the stuff that people did
and you can come up with yeah yeah you
can see out here
whatever you want to point to as like
the thing to me the level of difficulty
on that is higher than almost anything
else what is the greatest sports moment
in history for you and and not in terms
of like everyone has to agree but for
use like personally what is the greatest
so the greatest moment for me is going
to be the Sox winning an o4 Red Sox
winning 04. right I know I know Yankees
all that but I'm gonna see the greatest
moment in person and it's mainly because
I wrote a piece about this because Who's
involved so in order to have a great
Moment Like if you're sitting home on
your couch
you weren't there yeah it's like hey
high five and your friends or your
brother or whatever but it has to be in
person first I think and it has to
matter a little bit more to you guys
because of who who's there where you're
at and what you're with so the 99
All-Star Game my dad somehow through
work gets tickets for me him my brother
die hard Red Sox fans we grew up in Boss
we're all going there my grandfather is
a Die Hard fan my dad is I am Pedro is
like rejuvenated the franchise like the
most fun like incredible charismatic
pitcher I've ever seen favorite plant
team and we go to the game we're in the
locker room Ken Griffey Jr's there like
we did this is like the only time ever
we just had like full you know Willy
Wonka passes like my dad just made it
happen and I'm with my dad and my
brother we go to the game we go to the
All-Star Game it starts and Magic
Pedro's starting of course at Fenway
Park and he strikes out the first five
guys in the Ashley now it wasn't a
championship and it wasn't all that yeah
but like hugging your brother like oh my
God we're watching this happen live it
always is the first one that comes to my
mind that's a pretty good one uh you'll
appreciate this because you have a
brother uh when I was in like maybe late
Elementary early middle school for some
reason like there was no decision making
in our family it was like you are going
to be a Giants and a Yankees fan and I
decided that like I'm not going to do
that for like a two-year period and I'll
say I'm gonna be a Jets and a Mets fan
just to piss off my dad and uh Subway
series happens 2001 yeah and I'm the
oldest of five boys and pretty much the
only one who like should probably go to
the game in terms of like I'm like 11 or
you know whatever it is uh and he
doesn't take me he takes my brother and
I asked him years later I said why'd you
do that and he goes I wasn't going to
sit there and listen to you talk [__] to
me the entire time you suck and I'm like
you know what that's probably the like
best argument you could have made like
you definitely should not have taken me
that game I did the same thing I would
sit there chirping the whole time you
vibrate you like you you kind of like
move around the other teams that your
dad would hate yes remember like my
brother became a Bills fan for no reason
like I was an A's fan in the 90s because
of Ricky Henderson and all those guys
and like eventually you kind of migrate
back to like it would be cool to root
for the same yeah and if they suck they
suck but like they were right around the
time of like like I said it was right
around when they got players and it was
like oh wait maybe no more we'd always
guys it was fun so uh so for me I think
the Olympic uh there's an Olympic moment
that like I wasn't there or anything but
it it uh resonates so much is um what's
the guy uh Johnson I think is his last
name who he's running he pulls his
hamstring and uh he's hot he's like
hopping around and his dad comes out and
those types of moments I always think
like
nobody's running on the track in 2023
right or 2024 like there is way more
security now and so like we're kind of
robbed of a lot of those types of
moments when you look back on Sports
there's a bunch of different things that
happened where um I think there is uh uh
some guys ran on like the golf course or
whatever it's like a famous video right
they're like celebrating
hey Karen the guy's running around with
him shaking his hand
yeah bulldozed and hit probably tased at
this point literally right and so uh I
do think that there's like this element
of sports that like for security reasons
they can't do it anymore but uh that's
pretty cool to see right it was also I
mean I didn't live it like in a city
close enough but like when I interview a
lot of like the the older older
generation there was a lot of sneaking
in the games like the Love of the Game
was like sneaking in moving up in your
seats going up and scalping instead of
having to worry about if it's on
Ticketmaster you StubHub or whatever
like there was a bit more of like
it was kind of like free-flowing like
you could go and move seats and do
things and and I think yeah it's now
it's super corporate and also this is to
me the biggest part of that is like if I
want to know what any of the assets
we've just talked about are doing or any
of the athletes are doing I can use
their Instagram posting you didn't see
them if you were at the game you saw
them and maybe sportscentered but that
was it if I wanted to see Larry Bird we
had to go to Boston Garden and watch him
play if if I wanted it you know in the
2000s if I wanted to see Griffey I had
to wait till the Mariners came to Boston
to go watch him play like the access now
is in a certain way has ruined the like
the exclusivity with that kids have like
if my son wants to see Luka doncic
highlights he's just instantly on Lucas
feed there's four zillion Twitter
accounts YouTube accounts showing all
this stuff so when I finally do take him
to the first time he's going to see that
athlete he's literally watching
highlights in the car on the way there
whereas it used to be you were going to
see Larry Bird I was going to see
Michael Jordan for the very first time
the um the other thing uh that feels a
little weird is a lot of these guys uh
when you get the I don't know uh the
special like feeling or whatever taken
away yeah is that they act differently
as well yeah like we're we're recording
this and uh there's a story out that uh
John Morant was potentially in a truck
like in a car with other players and
they were like there's a red laser that
people think might have been a gun or
like like all this stuff that now is
coming out and you're just like
would people be doing some of this stuff
if Instagram didn't exist yeah right
like yes we get more access but also it
feels like some of the athletes do [__]
and you're just like why like what are
you doing you you have like I think it
was uh Shannon Sharpe was like you have
a 200 million dollar contract like chill
out you're not hard and you know what
else happens like you lose perspective
so one of the good things that a lot of
the best sports writers can do the you
know the Bob Ryan's the Howard Bryants
the guys who write these big books and
have followed over for years is like you
put the athlete in their perspective how
good they are historically what they
might mean to a city and that's why I
really like uh Ricky Henderson's
biography that he used to because it
really places where Ricky came from in
Oakland why he was how he was with his
Cockiness and confidence but also like
what molded him to be who he was and now
there's no context it's just crazy play
or athlete does this and there's no one
unless you know athletic I know there's
places that have it but you're so
exposed you're going to see them the
next day they're going to go on Twitter
and talk about it or go on Instagram
talk about it there was a little bit and
again I am all four athletes doing
whatever they want but we've lost a
little bit of context of like there was
somebody like this his name was Babe
Ruth by the way like you know it's like
when you talk about oh the the first guy
you know what LeBron does in Brandon
it's amazing Babe Ruth did all of it the
guy had his name on like 150 things he
had ghost written books he had plays he
was in the movies he had movies that he
was producing he had tobacco Coke gum
hor like horses like he hit he did
everything it was a hundred and twenty
years ago right 110 years ago so it
isn't that crazy what these guys are
doing it's just you see it all the time
and you know all the behind the scenes
stuff what's the Flex factory
it's my pride and joy this is how I
found you I have I have my son and my
daughter and my Flex Factor
[Laughter]
it's like a thing that I always wanted
to have
um so I spent a lot of time writing for
muscle and fitness and men's fitness
that's my my writing back when I came up
writing for those two magazines in GQ
well GQ is a bit of an outlier but
whatever anything that had men's or
muscle or Fitness or like dudes I could
write for in my in my 20s and uh and all
these athletes whenever I go travel to
interview them they just had these
badass Home Gyms like full Home Gyms I
know like the rock now with the iron
Paradise is probably the most famous
version but like I did a story with like
Batista and John Cena and he's got like
a barn on the side of his house that's
like a full Gold Gym that's his gym and
like Brock Lesnar when did a piece on it
he's got like this huge hanger that is a
full gin you've walked in you'd be like
oh does nobody go to this Gold Gym it's
like no it's just Brock Lesnar's that's
why no one's here right so I always
wanted like I'm not gonna have that but
I always wanted my version of it and
then you have kids and like working out
is just hard it's important to me I'm a
meatheaded heart like I'm not gonna not
lift but like you try to put it at lunch
at work and then you know I was just
telling earlier like you know you're
trying to time it right and then you you
take your pre-workout at like 11 15 and
then get called into a meeting and
you're like oh
you guys don't want me in this meeting
right now
you don't want me here and like it
time's off wrong and then you're just
like your heart rate's Jack but you're
just sitting there like yeah no that's a
good power play that's awesome you're
like under the table like your legs
moving so like I wanted to make it so
often does that happen not now I work
from home but it used to happen a bunch
I used to work for uh the Constable Hall
of Fame and like I loved it it was great
it was all football stuff but like we
had a gym right across the street and I
brought my kids to school early and all
of a sudden when I live in Texas and I
used to go to this LA Fitness it was
great and I would try every day it was a
joke in the office like I'd try to time
and be like if you take it yet because
we might have a meeting and I'm like
dude
fine well I'd you know put it back down
yeah and then but some days just
wouldn't work I'd be like halfway out
the door like hey can you come in we're
going to go over this thing with this
thing and I'd be like sweating already
like gosh yeah like I have red red I
always used to uh so obviously college
football like everyone's trying every
concoction they can possibly come up
with
um and uh uh the pre-workouts like
dominate right
um and there was guys who would be like
hey try this one because uh you get all
the energy like all the stuff but like
it doesn't give you the jittery feeling
yeah and I used to be like nah man I
don't know if that shit's working like
you need your face needs to be on fire
like you need to literally feel like
your skin is melting and then you're
like I don't know what's going on with
my body but like let's just go to the
gym yeah I remember and I would take it
anymore it's funny because now that I
have my own gym like all the science
behind like you know when you get up I
work out really early in the morning
like five five thirty and like you don't
want to be jamming caffeine and creatine
in your body right then so I actually
don't really I don't take any
pre-workout any at all ever
um but when I did like you just you feel
like the Hulk man like the good ones
where your heart rate would jack up and
like I remember one time I was like
racing down the banister and like I did
a swing around the bannister old house
and like ripped the banister off and I
was like first of all like that was
awesome second of all like I should
probably not in trouble yeah I was like
what was that I'm like nothing I'm like
I just pour hours apart my bare head so
in college I you know there's always
like these memories that you have where
you're like oh this is like a different
level and uh uh there's two specifically
but one that that uh just cracks me up
to this day is uh the strength and
conditioning coach there's this other
guy uh who was actually our running back
slash fullback or whatever uh his name
is Paul forsolini if he hears this he's
gonna [__] die so uh I'm moving in to
college I got my dad with me removing
like whatever [__] in and Paul and
his dad they're moving in and I swear to
you this dude literally walks up to the
elevator he's got like a [__]
refrigerator and like and I'm like okay
different world right like uh I probably
should go lift a little bit more before
we get on the field and so he gets hurt
and at one point uh um he says to me
he's like hey you should come down to
the weight room uh we're gonna try to
bench press I think it was 135 like a
hundred times in an hour or something
like like some you know like ridiculous
thing yeah strength coach you got this
guy and so they get started they're
going they're going and they keep going
around like the corner and I'm sitting
there like young kid whatever and all of
a sudden I'm like what the [__] is
around this corner and I go and they're
literally going into the cleaning supply
closet and the strength coach is like
sniffing the [__] like chlorine or
whatever and I literally remember saying
to myself like Oh I thought that was a
joke like I think people really did that
and he's like no it's better than
pre-workout and I literally were like I
don't care that much right like that was
that was where I remember thinking to
myself like I care but I don't care
enough to smell chemicals to lift yeah
and so I was like there's a trajectory
change here that is gonna end up with me
doing something else with my life to
trying to like go do this it's hard man
especially when you cover these guys the
levels are are insane the nutrient
timing they call it of like I remember I
did a feature uh with the strengthening
conditioning coach for the University of
Florida when Tim Tebow was there senior
year and this was like one of the most
athletic teams you'll ever find they had
a manual Moody transfer from USC they
had Tebow
um they had Aaron Hernandez at the time
but they had a bunch of dudes and this
is when he like is just like [__] like
[__] up by the way like if in that
interview all of them to a man like he's
the most impressive athlete we have like
strongest dude is a quarterback like a
couple linemen but like stronger than
online backers for sure hardest worker
like out there and he was talking about
like the you know they would do the uh
they go to the swamp at five in the
morning and do their Sprints and gassers
and then go and do their gym and it was
interesting because um Ryan Lochte went
there he was like working out for the
Olympics in in the gym there so it's
kind of cool and he would would talk
about like here's when we take the
creatine so it kicks in here and here's
the glucose and here's this and we're
watching heart rate for this and that
was when I was kind of realizing like
and I think they started having trackers
for heart rate monitors it wasn't like
the you know the Apple watch or Loop yet
or anything but like it was like okay so
so they know like 15 minutes from now
this is when's the best time to do
strength or stretch or whatever and like
you learn all these things from
interviewing these like elite elite
trainers and so that's when like you
understand that there's there's actually
a whole entire philosophy in science
people dedicate their lives to
optimizing their strength and
conditioning and it's like yeah so if
you're just the guy benching your
pre-worker in your garage like it's
great but like if I really wanted to do
it I could have a team of guys like yeah
yeah the uh the two stories with Tebow
that I uh always remember is um I think
it's in his book he says that he's at
like a high school uh summer camp and
one night in the dorm they're like uh
getting competitive with each other and
they're like hey let's see who can uh
curl this bicep bar uh the most and so
there's like a line of all the campers
and he keeps trying to move to the back
to the back to the back to the back and
he says he eventually gets a second to
last but the last guy won't let him get
behind him so he's like I stepped up and
I was like I have to do this so many
times that he doesn't pick it up yes and
so the most anyone had done is like 30
or 40 times and he claims he did it like
250 times like some stupid number right
and so the guy literally doesn't pick it
up whatever he he he wins but he's like
but I was the quarterback at camp and I
couldn't throw the next step
right man yeah and then the other story
is uh uh they were doing like a tug of
war type you know like workout where
it's you versus one other guy and for
those who don't know like usually they
kind of uh literally do tug of war but
like you pull somebody but it's not just
like pull the flag across the line it's
like you pull it until the coach
literally hits uh the whistle yeah and
so you like play to the whistle was like
the whole thing and um so when they were
doing it at Florida supposedly he was up
against a lineman or linebacker whoever
he was going against and he starts
pulling them and he literally is like
just yanking this kid and he pulls him
down the hallway into the bathroom
supposedly and he pulls and he like gets
into the bathroom he's like I literally
couldn't go any further back like I just
like ran out of space and then the coach
like Blows the Whistle and they're just
like yo quarterback is bodying right now
like not just doing it but like
embarrassing them and so when you look
at that you're like yeah that takes a
special type of person to not just have
the physical ability to do it but to
almost be like mentally in a state where
like that's the level that you want to
go to in order to uh assert your
dominance and like leadership in a team
right yeah he he really impressed me I
was so this is what maybe 10 years ago
whenever it was
um and I flew out there I'm you know
it's the guy and he was the most like
sought after name in maybe not all of
sports but definitely college football
and like he was his Q rating was through
the roof like he was about to win the
Heisman like he was the guy and he's a
young kid again like we talked about
LeBron like I would if I was that guy
like there's a real good chance I would
be an [__] all the time and everybody
like this Punk like he just was born
with this amazing ability but he they
all talked about how great he was and
you know the first and last to leave all
that cliche stuff but when I finally got
a chance to interview him it was like at
the end of the day he'd been working all
day I'm sure he had stuff to do and you
know their media guys like hey you got
you know you had 15 minutes so like I
interviewed a bunch the whole point was
like it was about the team but I did get
an interview with him he said hey how
you doing and he was like off like it
was so polite and like endearing it was
like I was like what he's like where are
you fly in from and the first time is
I'm like I don't want to waste all of it
but I found myself being interviewed
like but in a very polite really caring
way of like were you how long was the
drive because I lived in Florida I was
like lived out here I was like any
traffic yeah it's tough around there
um what do you live with your girlfriend
like just the whole
conversation and I was like yeah and I'm
like all of a sudden like hey man let me
uh let me ask a couple questions yeah
like you're awesome and you're nice but
like if I don't get these quotes on this
whole story sucks but you're really
great and I'm gonna say that you're
great but like he laughed and the guy
was like you know how often that happens
like one of the immediate people they're
like he just whatever it is you can't
[__] that there's no way I don't
care you don't care you're not going to
just talk to some random guy who you
said you have 15 and I've and the reason
I know this is because I've had so many
athletes over the years who are just
[__] like who you who give you that
15 minutes and aren't even remotely
putting their thought or Focus who's the
biggest [__]
um biggest ass oh there's a guy I'm
gonna say it because uh there was a guy
who I did a cover story with and it was
supposed to be for muscle fitness and I
don't even know if he's in sports now I
have no idea and I think he would own up
to it because he was a jerk we flew
there to do an actual cover story shoot
with him we had a photography crew and
it was a guy he played for the race for
a while Evan Longoria and whether he
whether he was having a bad day some of
these guys have him some of these guys
don't he'd been in the league for a
while so it wasn't like a rookie type of
thing and he was just like he wasn't
into it and we're like we need just
we're gonna put you on the cover and he
wouldn't you know look I always he
wouldn't answer questions or he was just
not really posing for the stuff he was
like all these guys are here they'll be
gone soon and like you know what do you
work out he's like I don't really work
out like it was muscle fitness I'm like
what do you do the weight training he's
like I hate weights that kind of stuff
and I'm like you realize like you could
have just said no to this whole piece
like he wasn't really in great shape at
the time again I always being honest I
always always put out like they are
allowed to have bad days yeah we're
there for a job maybe something happened
is like I always say that I don't in
life he may be great but for that four
hours and my my photographer did a ton
of shoots with all the WWE guys we left
and he was like dude something's up like
that was rough like we're not gonna use
it there's nothing to use we called our
home and they're like what and I was
like we don't have we didn't do the
cover so like maybe a great guy but in
terms of like and I don't won't even
call him an [__] in terms of a rough
rough experience yeah that was the
toughest thing and he'll listen you have
a huge volley Evan I'm sorry but like
that day was brutal like we flew all the
way out there from LA to Tampa and we
didn't get the cover story and uh who
knows maybe he's Jack now we'll do it
again
I love it uh you also wrote a book about
dads uh and their ability to continue to
work out you have kids what it is you
said you wake up early and you work out
five five thirty like what's your daily
schedule yeah so the reason I came up
with the or the reason I had the garage
gym I always wanted a name of the Flex
factory like it just oh so you had the
name before the gym yeah I'll tell you
that so I interviewed Triple H this is
true story interview Triple H for a
cover story legend legend right deact
the whole thing and I was talking he had
kids and I know I almost got suspended
from middle school for doing it yeah
that was a big thing like that was out
of school but like I remember here I was
literally in middle school and like for
those that don't know WWF at the time uh
there was a group and they were
basically going around and they were
taking their yeah they were taking a
cross across their crotch area saying
suck it and if you're a young
impressionable boy you see that you're
like that's awesome and you would do it
to like each other like as a joke it was
like a like kind of like an endearing
light you wouldn't actually do it to
start a fight yeah no right definitely
not but of course teachers see it then
it becomes like a thing and the parents
like what's going on like all the like
any High School College we went to kids
scored a touchdown they're all doing it
yeah it became part of culture to some
degree and I was in uh I'm pretty sure
it was like late middle school and kids
were like doing it all the time and uh I
think I like did it like at a friend
down the hall but of course it's like
classic I got them on their movie right
no like the teacher is like coming
around the corner and like sees it right
and you're just like now you'd be like
whatever like obviously it wasn't
directed towards you yeah but there
can't be any disrespect in a middle
school and so I remember I had to like
have a meeting and like do all this
stuff don't you know Triple H no no I
literally was like oh my God I'm gonna
like get in trouble for this and so I
always remember are thinking back like
dude schools are so stupid but also like
they have to keep some element of
control yeah kids running up and down
doing suck it yeah well true story so I
but my son is into wrestling now and we
watch all Friday Night Smackdown and
when I raw and they did a 30th
anniversary of raw two weeks ago and
they brought those guys back and for the
first time ever my son sees the suck it
and I can't get him to stop walking
around he's nine he's perfect perfect
literally like nine to 13 is like you
got him he has a whole like you know
kids have like you know ring Andrew he
has like a ring exit to go to school
every day he came up with it's awesome
and like now he does this added to it
it's amazing and so uh it reminds me of
the uh Mark Cuban you ever seen the
video Cuban at a uh he's on the
sidelines like he walks off the bench or
something uh to a kid and a kid is
trying to like uh shake his hand and so
Cuban walks over he like begrudgingly
like walks over and he's like all right
I'm gonna give this kid and then the kid
dabs on him and Mark just looks at him
he's got this look of like are you
and it's an amazing video because you're
just like in that moment he's just like
I can't be mad because like this
probably the highlight of this kid's
life right now that he just dabbed on
Mark Cuban but also like kid yeah my son
will like getting filled like fight with
my daughter and end it with this and
you're like
good job like you use it correctly and
I'm kind of proud of you but like you
really can't do it now it's old first of
all people go what the hell where'd you
come up with that but it's awesome to
watch them take uh take all this stuff
in so um so Triple H I was interviewing
him for a cover story and um he switched
the time a bunch which happens whatever
all the time and he finally calls he's
like yeah I just uh I just move things
around and I just made a joke like oh
you know trying to get the gym in
because a lot of these guys
um they travel 300 days a year or
whatever like the the move to get over
jet lag for almost all of them to a man
is hit the gym immediately like get off
the plane hit the gym like if you're
sweating get your stuff in you get it
done and then you can kind of figure it
out so I just threw that I was like no
I'm actually because he was already kind
of an executive already homies actually
work out at like midnight too and I was
like what and he's like I you know I
have kids now and I want to be home for
them in the morning at breakfast and
like there's no way he's talking like or
Triple H he's like there's no way I can
do this and I can't leave the house in
the morning during the day I can't live
so I just I think it's James Franco one
he's a big like uh
big Power lifter helps train him I'm
probably boss the name but whatever it
is anyway so he works out so I was like
man that's what happens to me all the
time on a much smaller scale I'm not
running the WWE but like I run out of
time so I had started like bringing
exercise stuff home for random stuff so
I had some dumbbells some cables you
know some bands a couple uh you know a
couple like ropes to do stuff jump ropes
and then I was like I'm gonna do like I
want to be able to just work get it done
before the kids are sleep but this is my
kids were like one in three two and four
like they're finally sleeping through
the night which is as anyone knows like
amazing you can't complain you can't do
anything or plan an early morning
workout if you're up three different
times because at night terrors or potty
training or whatever so when they
finally I could count on that
um I just like slowly added [__] like I
got like a squat rack and then I got
like an incline bench they're an incline
decline bench and then I got like
heavier weights and then I got a set of
plates and then all of a sudden I was
like this is the greatest thing ever
like I started going all in I got a hex
bar and like slam balls and the on it
kettlebells with the gorilla on them and
like I was like I gotta you know I have
all these posters from growing up like
my Reggie Lewis poster and Mike
Greenwell and The Sultans of Slam I'm
like I'm gonna I'm gonna like make this
I don't need a man cave I don't want
some room to watch TV I don't care like
I can watch it wherever this is gonna be
like my right spot yeah and I had this
stuff I have Larry Bird posters from
when I was like 10 like so the whole
wall now is basically like Frozen in
time in like 1991 and uh and I get up
every day about 5 15. sometimes 5 30 and
I still 6 30 full hour
um I do like power lifting and on stuff
one day and bodyweight stuff and
dumbbells and switch I have you know
from all my time muscle fitness immense
fin like I have a zillion workouts to
pull from so I just kind of rotate
through
um and then I finish at 6 30 ish 6 40 I
wake up my kids my daughter's already up
now my son it takes like 15 minutes to
get him out of bed and do all that [__]
um then we have breakfast and I'm making
my smoothie driving to school walk the
dog and you know start the day at like
eight o'clock
it's not bad it's pretty good the dog
walks my favorite part because like
workout done kids are like off to school
you know never know what's going to
happen with them they eat breakfast
don't eat breakfast forgot their
homework need five bucks for a field
trip like it's chaos even on the ride
like oh you know I always tell my kid
like telling me you had a homework to do
today in the car on the ride to school
is not telling me you had homework to do
it's telling me you forgot to do your
goddamn homework and there's nothing we
could do about it because I'm pulling
into the parking lot in five minutes so
like it's always that kind of stuff so I
get home the 20 minute dog walk we have
a lab she's great like on one line ready
to go get home you know shower real
quick by 8 15 8 30 like it's time to
write time to get to work yeah the um uh
my daughter is not old enough yet for
homework but uh when I think about
anything to do with homework I'm just
like dude I put out a tweet a while ago
one of my best ones I wrote Finkel
hating homework since third grade hating
Homer since College hating homework
helping a third grader hating homework
since the beginning of homework stop it
I'm like everyone parent was like yes
yes yes yes I mean like literally right
so much work it's so stupid when we used
to get home from school my uh mom used
to make us sit at the table and like do
our homework before we go outside or
like do whatever and uh I mean we like
would cheat on the homework in front of
our mom not like cheat like in like
cheat in school like we would be like
we're done yeah he would sit there for
three minutes be like no no I'm done I
finished it all and we'd be like uh
they'd send you home with like the
assignment you know thing whatever we
were like trying to like erase [__] like
whatever we could possibly do to make
convince her that we were done we would
try and I think back I'm like we
probably should just done the homework
done faster forget knowing how to do it
we just been done quicker than if we had
spent all that time trying to trick our
mom into thinking our homework was done
see well now the whole new thing is now
is like I'll be in my office writing or
working like you guys are doing your
homework same thing at the kitchen table
all of a sudden you're like Alexa what's
43 divided by 17 I'll be like you can't
you that's not well you're I don't want
to bother you it's like okay wait so you
just gonna completely cheat ask Alexa
all the answers because you don't want
to walk 15 feet I appreciate it but like
you know so I'll go in and you know help
but like there's so many you know tricks
and stuff now who knows what chat what's
gonna happen when they're older but like
they ask Alexa everything like so what's
the capital of Senegal and it's like you
can't you have to this is what the
book's for this is why you're supposed
to like so like I go back and forth on
this as of like yes I've seen the like
you know whatever the the second grader
or whatever being like two plus two
Alexa like whatever it's like four
you're like ah you probably should know
that one but uh 43 divided by 17 like
yeah I might ask excellent I might
double check if it was if it was
recorded like no public math my son my
son got ahead of it he goes Alexa am I
ever gonna need to know what an
isosceles triangle is I was like now
this is a kid he's got he's gone past
what it is he's gone right to do I need
to know this [__] Alexa because you know
everything
Alexis like a kid do your homework she's
like uh your parents in the room like
okay if your dad's not there then no
that's just your dad's there then we
have to have that conversation uh and
also I think that like
most people's jobs they just Google
anyways everything right like I spent I
don't know more time than I admit
looking [__] up all day yeah so like
actually if you know how to do that
maybe asking Alexis cheating but like
you know if you could use Google then
maybe you're actually prepared they cut
you down because like my my boy will
come home and be like Dad I had to write
a paper today like really wasn't hard
that's just what you do right stuff
yeah I do you little [__] that is what I
do it wasn't hard it wasn't hard I mean
I just had to like think of things I'm
like yeah that's it he's like so that's
that's what that's kind of it now he's
you know now I'm like you see this 300
Page books like you know pulling out the
dude look at the references like trying
to find a way to impress him and he's
like yeah no I could do that I would
just have to sit down a couple times
yeah just think about it yeah just think
about it and put it down I'm like let me
see what you wrote you know it's like
Daniel Boone War I'm like okay you know
what that's good yeah Wikipedia yeah
uh when you think about uh the
intersection of your life you got this
newsletter uh biceps and books books and
biceps books and biceps all right
I mean perfect name right uh what is the
like the the goal of this is it to find
books for Meatheads or is it actually to
expand past that audience hey guys I
hope that you're enjoying this
conversation as you probably realize we
don't run any ads on this show that's
right all the other podcasts all the
other YouTube shows that you watch they
have advertisers we don't have any
direct relationships with advertisers
and we simply create this because we
enjoy doing it now that we do that
though we have a team and if you'd like
to support us one way you can do that is
to go subscribe to the pomp letter it's
a daily letter that I write to about 235
000 people about my personal opinion on
financial markets business technology
and Bitcoin just go to pompletter.com
and you can sign up there I'd love to
have you join us and it's a great easy
way to support the work that the team
and I are doing on a daily basis all
right let's get back into this
conversation yeah it's like so I always
like newsletters that share people's
process and stuff so anybody but he can
do like the wrap up stuff I love your
book reviews like what did you get from
this stuff well I come across when I'm
researching a book I might find 50 books
for that book just touching upon it or
articles and things like that or I may
find a concept in the book that I want
to explore more and then also I happen
to have written for all these Fitness
magazines and I work out a lot so it's
like just sharing a little bit of what
goes on behind the scenes and putting a
book together and sort of the lifestyle
that puts the book together so I always
say it's like imagine you're like
educated Meathead friend was like
recommending workouts and books to you
every week that's it it's like the smart
guy like the idiot guy who you think's
in the gym who also reads he's got some
things that you might want to check out
that's kind of the the ethos of it and
so every week like I share a book like
why I liked it a lot of times I do get
to do author interviews which is cool
over all the years I know like so a lot
of people have books coming out that I'm
going to read they'll do three or four
questions for me and I try not to ask
like lame ass questions it's more like
do you write a coffee shop right here
like what do you listen to when you're
like real Authority type stuff and then
the biasis part is I'm a meathead man I
just post pictures on my garage Jim I do
put a lot of stuff in there that helps
me especially I've gotten older like you
know posture stuff hip flexor stuff like
things will help you as you you know
like to recover
um if you're trying to get strength if
you're trying to do these things so it's
really what I'm doing now or what I've
read now but what I found is there's a
huge contingent of guys like us who grew
up working out exercising who are now
have kids kids are getting older they
don't have time to read they don't want
to look for stuff is this a good book
that's coming out oh cool I have a
filter for it and you know what I do
want to start benching again like a lot
of the things that I write on the
fitness side I'm just responding to
questions like uh I want to start like
benching again like what's a good
program or what's a basic like
powerlifting program to do and I'm like
oh the 5x5 and here's why and actually
here's an article I wrote eight years
ago that will help you or you know I
want to start swimming which I swim a
big one like I've done a bunch of like
starter swimming workouts so it's really
just to help out and then also you know
you build over book over book you build
readership and they don't really always
cross over maybe somebody who read 1996
isn't going to read a fatherhood book
who might not be into the Macho Man
Randy Savage but like they've all bought
a book for me and it kind of gets a
little through line I think it's smart
to have them have a little bit of
knowledge about who you are how you put
books together and how you live it's
interesting because James Clear I was
listening to an interview he did with uh
maybe it was Tim Ferriss or somebody and
he talks about uh they picked three
segments of people when they launched
Atomic habits and one of them was
CrossFit and so he sent free books to a
bunch of CrossFit influencers and his
point was like if you're in CrossFit
there was like a four week period where
everybody in the CrossFit world was
posting this book and he was trying to
unpack in hindsight why they all
accepted the book and posted whatever
because like because everyone always
sends them workout [__] yeah right he's
like I was the one who sent him a book
and they all wanted to have their
audience think they were not just a
meathead yeah so like hey here's this
book that I'm reading about habits and
like everyone like it like makes sense
in hindsight but it was like fascinating
that he was like that led to kind of the
initial spark that eventually led to you
know one of the best-selling books in uh
in the last couple years yeah I think
that's a huge thing and he's he's
brilliant with those end insights and
it's right when you see it in practice
because you get how many people start
living that lifestyle a little bit with
you right like I did a giveaway of
stickers it's just a nothing thing but
like gone 50 of them gone in like 10
minutes within the second the newsletter
gets out and you realize that yeah
people who work out a lot
um and are into it they're not morons
most of them there's the Bros always
juicing or whatever but like a lot of
them are just dads and dudes trying to
stay safe moms too you know and women
trying to get in shape and what are
books that might interest them a lot of
people don't read a lot
um and I think what you do is great you
pick a lot of cross-sections of maybe
people who aren't into investing or into
Bitcoin but like this is a great
philosophy this is a great lifestyle
thing to think about this is just a
great way to look at life new in a New
Direction and so I'll put like it's got
definitely Sports and maybe history-ish
heavy but a lot of it is like really
good writing really good writers that I
like um have you read this new book that
just came out here's why I bought it
here's the author here's why I admire
this author um and the the emails that I
get back people respond pretty regularly
are you know that's great I I love that
I think I'm going to buy this book or
whatever it is but also it's the same on
the fitness side so to the same thing as
CrossFit anyone who's like grew up
loving these Sports is gonna like the
books and if they're that that niche of
like that Venn diagram of like you know
I have like books you know biceps like
Meat Heads like if you're in there maybe
it's not 50 million people but it might
be two I'll take it those are my that's
my group that's my crew I love it uh you
said you start working eight eight
fifteen so after you've kind of done all
the morning routine what do you do
during the day yeah so I have a bunch of
like creative Consulting where I do a
lot of copywriting so I used to do like
a ton of stuff for Fitness Brands Muscle
Milk cytosport Gatorade all those kind
of things so I do a lot of work for
Brands around you know around local and
National just on helping them with their
products uh helping them like just you
know go through and you know put like
the copy for how we gonna Market this
protein shake to this or this cryo
Center that we're putting together for
this so I do a lot of those sort of
client work and then the bulk of what I
do is books so I have um right now I'm
like deep in the Weeds on a macho man
any Savage biography so that's like the
book I actually ghost right too so I
usually have one or two ghost writing
books with pretty usually professional
athletes like kind of elite entrepreneur
CEO type so I usually have a couple
those take longer because you're only
talking at their schedule maybe once
every week or two
um 45 minutes so walk me through if
you're writing a book like the uh Macho
Man uh book what does that process look
like how long will it take you so the
you know that one's gonna end up being
over a year so it's like if you're
talking from idea like I've always I
want to write a macho man book since I
was like 12. but like you put a proposal
together
um it's really in depth it's like
everything you would do for the book uh
who the audience is why they would want
it you know who are comp titles
um what you're how you're going to
present it what are the platforms you
you know promoted on not just your
social but like who are all the places
that would like it who's going to review
it you know a whole thing sometimes a
sample chapter sometimes not I've not
enough books now that I can do but
here's Charlie Ward like here's how I
write or whatever but sometimes a sample
chapper a chapter of what you're going
to do with it and you pitch it and then
you know hopefully a traditional
publisher wants it or like I did with
Jackson Chief I'll just put it at Macho
I wanted to go with a legit big
publisher because I want it out in
stores I wanted to work with a a
publisher uh who has done wrestling
books before particularly so they can
reach that really rabid crazy wrestling
audience and so uh once you get past all
that the publisher says yes and you have
an advance and you're starting the
beginning is just absolute research like
finding and interviewing every possible
person who ever had anything to do with
this person
um and then going through And archiving
the interview so you know what
specifically to ask these people about
so the beginning it's almost just like
fire hose of like I'm just Googling and
I know the things but like you know you
go in there's a couple resources one of
the best is a place called
newspapers.com and it like somehow
they've archived every newspaper maybe
80 of them all the way back to like the
1800s so you'll just do like 1952 Angelo
paffo right and marching Man's dad what
comes up and just go I will seriously go
year by year with certain keywords
wrestling this that just to get a feel
of that then look at like I know the
list of people I want to talk to Hacksaw
Jim Duggan and Ricky the Dragon
Steamboat a Million Dollar Man and like
you know I know that major list that
everybody else can name but this books
anybody who writes biographies will tell
you like it's the other people it's the
guy who sat next to him on the bench in
his high school baseball ball team some
minor league baseball player he lifted
with it you know in the morning before
games those are like those put the
stories together so I'll spend how do
you find those people
in questions really it's like pulling a
thread you get one Facebook groups are
actually like really good so like the
class reunion group for the Macho Man
Macho Man with the Downers Grove High
School in Illinois there's they just had
their 25th reunion or whatever 35th
Anniversary we'll do public math as you
say whatever it is they just had an
interview they just had a reunion and I
found the Facebook page for it and I was
you know just messaging here's what I'm
doing and one or two people got back to
me and luckily one of them was like one
of the social leaders now they're all in
their 70s and you had a great
conversation he actually uh he played
baseball or basketball with him his
freshman year new Lany a little bit
lanny's his brother leap and Lanny poffo
um you know here's who else you should
talk to who that's the the key for
anyone I mean the question you have to
ask yourself is when you're done with
the interview you say who else should I
talk to about this what else is there
something I'm missing what else should I
know like those two questions will get
you like 50 of the better stories in
your book I'm sure you do it even with
this like what what is the other thing
who else was on that team that you might
know that might still be around and you
just pull that thread and all of a
sudden that one phone call will lead to
two will lead to three we'll lead to
five you know some of them are just work
like macho man was in Spider-Man as bone
saw McGraw remembers you know like it's
awesome and uh you know I found a couple
interviews he did while on set but I
like went through Instagram and scoured
and I found the he was bone saw McGraw
in the movie there are some like sort of
extras but they kind of have bit Parts
called the bonettes these these four
girls who accompanied him to the ring
well I found some bonettes no way what
was it like being on set with him what
was it like walking what was it off
behind the scenes when you weren't
filming what was the director Sam Ramey
was the director like how did he
interact with Macho like that kind of
stuff and you just dig and dig and dig
and it's these little moments that make
it all worth it when you sounds goofy
but like when the bonette DM me back and
was like I'd love to talk about Randy he
was great and it's like I have I have
eyes onto a major movie that he was on
awesome and then she had someone else to
talk to and so you do that with every
little scene in their lives and
eventually you talk to hundreds of
people and then you start pulling the
articles about those things and that's
that's how you know when you finally
have enough for each section that you're
comfortable with and there's no limit
you just eventually get to a point where
you're like I think I've exhausted his
high school baseball career you just
start writing
and when you start writing how much of
it is like uh I already have all the
information now I just got to kind of
play editor versus like you sit down you
have it in your head and you just start
writing so I like to start every chapter
as if no one's read any other part of
the book I mean for the most part like
it could stand alone so that they'll
come in different spots a lot of writers
that I've always liked do that
um and so like for for instance Randy
Savage like people people may or may not
know he was a really baseball Prospect
like he played for the Reds uh he played
for the Tampa tarpons he was good he
made it a single a All-Star team twice
like so you want to talk to people all
through that at a certain point you're
hearing the same stories over you're
like there's probably not much more here
in this case um his brother Lanny Papa
who you know unfortunately passed away
last week I was talking to him a lot and
I had banked a bunch of interviews with
him about Randy's life and so
um once I have us during those
conversations with these people is when
I'll start pinning like this is a great
place to start I try to start on action
sometimes you can't always start in like
the middle of a you know flying elbow
drop off the top rope or like when he's
getting a baseball brawl it can't always
be like jumping in the middle of an
action movie you sometimes need context
but I always try to start in that like
what is the inciting incident of this
chapter what is the thing that if I'm
reading at night because I always put
myself like very few people at two in
the afternoon like I'm gonna have an
energy drink and sit and read all fired
up it's like you're whining out at the
end of the day maybe they're lying in
bed maybe they're you know sitting wait
outside of their cars saying like what's
going to get them like this chapter's
exciting they're in it all of a sudden
they're two pages in and we're going and
so usually I have a little good radar
now after 10 or 15 books of like I'll
make a little highlight and even in the
conversation like and I'll just do it in
bold like I write badass badass like
okay and then as I go through my notes
I'll just search like fine search badass
and it's like okay this is a good story
to open this chapter this is a good
story to open this chapter what about uh
when you're writing or you're doing it
at home I do music coffee shop coffee
shop okay I do when I'm at a coffee shop
uh there's a local one I have that I go
to a lot which is I think I I wrote it
the other day like in Twitter like I
reached the final boss level of coffee
shop writing I walk in I get a head nod
and they roll over and meet me at the
table with with I just get like a small
coffee yeah um and they know and they
know and I just pay for it when on my
way out like that is you know it used to
be and the best part about this coffee
shop is because I have my Macho Man [__]
spread everywhere and a couple of the
guys don't speak English great they just
call me Macho so not only like have I
reached like here's your coffee it's
like hey Macho and I'm like this is I'm
never leaving here
all right and do you listen to music I
listen to the coffee shop I'll just the
coffee shop sounds are good they
actually have a pretty good like 90s
station they put on or whatever
um at home funny enough I used to listen
to music like explosion in the sky or
Jimi Hendrix I like a lot like three
little three little birds some of these
like over and over again Bob Marley I'm
sorry
um over and over again but uh I found
this goofy YouTube thing that is just
coffee shop background noise
dude it's the weirdest thing it's got
like millions of millions of you so I'm
not so I was just gonna say there's some
of these there's like that there's one
uh uh I've seen they have different
locations like the sounds of a certain
place there's fire uh I don't like a
fireplace fire they do like warm rain
mountain and that's one of the funny
things about like becoming an author as
I am like growing up in movies it's like
okay when you write like you go to a
house in the Hamptons or like some
beautiful cabin in the mountains it's
secluded no I just put on [__]
YouTube three weeks away no one's
bothering you and now it's like yeah I
wrote at the mechanic today I wrote
outside of my kids Taekwondo I wrote it
the colic it's not like that uh but the
coffee shop sounds it's weird I listen
to the same one over it I've tried a
bunch like I know the Cadence of this
one hour I know where I am in writing
like oh the hour is up I know the people
in the background weirdly like oh that's
the person's gonna come in in five
minutes and talk about like their finals
getting canceled or whatever it's really
weird so weird so that I caught myself
the other day listening to the coffee
shop background noise at the coffee shop
and then I knew I'd like crossed over
into some metaverse where like I need to
pull back yeah yeah but I do think
everyone has like uh music specifically
or like sound I think uh you always
remember where you are and like what
you're doing yep when I wrote the
Charlie Ward book I spent a week in
Thomasville Georgia his hometown and
they had an amazing coffee shop I think
it was called like the Greenville coffee
shop or something and uh they had a
great comment I don't even one cup of
coffee a day I just would have it while
I'm while I'm drinking while I'm writing
and uh they had they would always play
this and I had to find it I'm blanking
on it now but it was like uh it was like
Beethoven or Mozart one of those and it
was always in the back and it was very
relaxing and I would write after the end
of the day of doing interviews and stuff
I'd go there and have like these amazing
like pralines and cream cookies or
whatever and you know for a week they
get to know you a little bit oh he's the
guy doing the Charlie award book
whatever and I listen to it when I
finally got home and again I changed it
up for every book just so because it
does bring back stuff I want it sounds
stupid like I want to get into like when
I listen to this this is what I listen
to yes while I'm writing this like the
life of dad but for some reason I wasn't
like Dave Matthews from my college I
listened over and over like the same
three songs whenever I hear it I'm like
I finished that book so in the Charlie
Ward book for the rest of it when I got
home uh I was listening to like
Beethoven's not the fifth like the big
one but it was like background one and
every time I hear it because it's in
movies and all that it takes me
immediately back to that Cafe it's weird
I um uh the only time in my life that I
have uh this like specific recollection
is uh
I was a catcher in baseball for like uh
years and years and years and one of the
coaches was like hey man you should uh
pitch and I was like uh why and he's
like well there's like a two-way
relationship here and you already got
one side down it's like so I remember
being like all right fine and for
whatever reason uh I have like remember
the uh uh kids now would be like oh old
school like Boombox things or whatever
yeah and we had got like a super cheap
one or whatever and we had he put the CD
in there and you like put it kind of
perfectly so that it doesn't [__]
rock or anything and the CD skips the
whole thing and uh lim biscuit had uh
had come out and uh whatever the song
was and I just remember like whenever I
would hear that I'd be like I remember
being in the backyard [__] throwing a
baseball being like well the coach is
stupid enough to put me up there like I
better just not hit the hit the batter
like as long as I don't do that I'll be
good and it is funny how like you do
kind of through your life have these
sounds that always resonate and you
remember like what you were doing when
you either first heard it or you heard
it on on repeat or whatever uh and it's
a cool way to bring those memories back
yeah I just had that with so I drove up
to Tampa for so Macho Man lived in Tampa
the end of his life and when he when he
died he had a heart attack while driving
his car and he crashed into a tree and
he'd already died but it was like a
pretty crazy moment like his his wife
was in the car like she had to pull the
tree like they were going to oncoming
traffic like she reached for the wheel
because he's like a 220 pound dude who
just like slumped over and she hit this
tree and this tree has become kind of
like a de facto Memorial a memorial for
Macho Man like uh so I always I had to
go visit at Sea and I want his house was
close to there I wanted to go get a feel
for it so I drove out with my daughter
and you know the deal was like I let her
come on the road trip with me and she
just like I just want to listen to my
music like my brother you know worst
thing ever is I let them rotate songs in
the car in the morning it's just a fight
it's like Metallica and Taylor Swift
Just back-to-back jar each other so she
just listened to Taylor Swift over and
over and over again and uh Shake It Off
like they take it off yeah and over on
re I would Zone outload ever talking and
now it's only it's been like a couple
weeks and as I'm writing like forever
Taylor Swift Shake It Off well for me
will be linked to the Macho Man Randy
obviously what he would have listened he
would have loved it yeah yeah
um the the other piece uh that's like
very fascinating to me about all of this
is uh you write about sports or sports
related topics but you also have written
a bunch of blogs and kind of Articles
and things like that uh one of them I
was reading and I literally was like
this is me and my brothers is 250. which
is a driveway game that you all uh
created yeah and I'll put some context
around this so my daughter just got
um uh like a child basketball uh hoop
and so of course you know first thing I
literally got put together the second I
was done putting it together I got the
ball and I said hey come here and she
kind of waddled on over and I put it
right underneath the basket and I dunked
on her just to the number one yeah just
don't stand under the rim like rule
number one of life don't sit under the
rim
um but I was explaining my wife I was
like look if we had this in our house as
a kid like we would have made up a game
and she's like what do you mean I'm like
well if you see her on the tile like you
know the three tiles away would be
certain points and like I started she
was like are you this [__] psychos
and I was like I'm pretty sure every boy
everyone who has a brother something
similar and I was reading your piece and
so 250 is a game you guys created I'm so
happy brother this is the greatest thing
I'll Ever Write no matter what I do ever
this is it because it touches on I mean
I've had guys write me like I'm crying
as I'm writing this like this brings
back my older guys maybe my son or
whatever something happened so it's
probably the piece that's resonated the
most and it's the one that resonated the
most with me so growing up as a younger
brother and I best friends my dad and I
are close uh the three of us are very
very close and one of the games we came
up with you know eventually as you're
doing on your daughter like you just
start working your dad right like you're
playing three you know two two we play
you know hustle or 21 the three of us
and friends would come over but like
once you hit like 13 14 15 even if
you're like I think I'm in pretty good
shape but I'm pretty sure my son's 15
he's gonna just be biting me up and
killing me the first time you beat your
dad you're on right and we literally
your family's the same nobody is ever
allowed to win like you win you won by
your own like grit and guts like
nobody's ever like oh hey let me like
and to this day like my son doesn't win
unless like he wins wins and so as we
got older like we'd start switching from
like hustle and one-on-one or two on one
where we play you know my dad was never
a great athlete
um but an amazing eyehand coordination I
think you said specifically in the piece
that uh with the foul line he couldn't
jump
yeah yeah he couldn't draw the foul line
darts pool like anything where you're
standing I hate coordination was great
um and so as we got older like it became
we're gonna even play horse anymore
because we would all be too competitive
and go all the way around or my brother
and I would decide to play so far away
that my dad just couldn't get it up
there he's in like 45 or now that almost
happened like 50 55 years old he
couldn't reach it when you're a kid by
the way you you definitely like do all
the things that uh your dad can't do
like three dribbles with your right hand
crossover jump off your left foot and
then like hook shot oh he's like I can't
even [__] remember this all we would
do is jump and touch the back over their
left hand and lay up with the right and
he'd be like I can't do this [__] why
are you no I can't do this [__] you know
every time my brother who can jump
higher than me would then pull it on me
and be like I'm gonna grab the rim and
lay up and be like I can't do this [__]
right so I was like just a never-ending
game so we came up with this game is the
perfect equalizer anyone who has a
driveway hoop daughter son I probably
play with both of them now it's 250.
very simple rules all you do is the
first person to 50 wins it's like
baseball rules you get up first shoot
till you miss next person goes first
person to get the 50 wins and you get
your last stops it's all like uh free
throws free throws at the free throw
line that's all you do
um it's perfect because you can do it
after dinner like everyone's just
relaxed you don't have to get sweaty
just had a couple cheeseburgers you're
hanging out no big deal and so we
started playing this game my last year
being home in high school and my
brother's three years younger so the
sophomore and then forever home every
cop we play thousands and thousands of
this game and um my dad as he got older
the thing that used to kill us about
this was he would always be like in his
recliner inside watching like a Red Sox
game or Seinfeld or whatever and we'd
like knock on the window like eight
o'clock in the summer as the sun was
going down after we played like real
games like I had to 50 and he had come
out and it used to be so frustrating
because he would come out in like
docksiders
and my father he's like six one a husky
guy again not a great athlete but I had
for some reason he was gifted with an
unbelievable ability to hit free throws
this guy who who couldn't like do a jump
shot like could not like come around a
screen would stand up having not shot he
used to do this thing every time I could
do it now rub his hands and hit 25 in a
row 30 in a row cold and he used to be
like I don't need any warm-ups and my
brother who's an excellent High School
basketballer Captain high school team
captain of his high school team and then
me just okay
um would just just be like so frustrated
and uh him and my brother would win all
the time I to this day have never won
you've never won with my dad involved
okay on Christmas Day I beat my brother
and both our sons in a legit to 50 game
for like the first time I've ever beat
my brother I'm not a good battle
Shooters but my dad would probably win
like 70 of the time how pissed was your
brother this Christmas Furious because
it was the first time our sons were both
nine they're two months apart it was the
first time we all played me he me and
him built his hoop at his house like the
end of the summer kids weren't really
old enough to play with a real ball from
real foul line they just got strong
enough and it was the first time for the
record we ever the four of us played 50
uh and I and I won and he was like my
brother's like an awesome athlete it was
very very pissed off so Craig it's on
posterity now it's on the pump everybody
knows literally I'm imagining my
brothers and I playing something they're
like if I knew I was better than at it
they know too yeah right and vice versa
and like they won't admit it but like
whatever and then if in front of our
kids they beat me and now our kids think
that like they're better yeah well
what's funny is we play back we play I
would sit there and make you play over
and over and over again until they know
literally I am better than him we play
one-on-one every Friday morning
still every Friday right now he lives 15
minutes from he drives over we play in a
court in my development
we play best of three uh games to 11 and
since he's moved here a year and a half
ago I have not won I win games all the
time 11 through 13 but I never he just
he's tell he's an inch too taller me bet
a better basketball player but we play
all time and so winning that game to 50
I was like am I I'm this is weird but
you're a good brother for this because
like
my brothers and I we that uh tradition
would end quickly if like one person
didn't win I know I think it's an age
thing like I I won I beat him plenty of
times growing up yeah it's just I think
I've reached the point where like when I
reached out for that third gear and our
games you know some games he just Moss
Florida but like most of the time like
I'll win one he'll win one and the next
one's a battle but he can always just go
down lows way better down low and like I
just get cold at the wrong times I'll
foul the [__] out of them I'll do all
this I'm supposed to do and I've come
I'm right there it's not like I I win
all time just not that third clinching
game yeah so winning the 250 game was
amazing but to the piece you're talking
about going back so on the so after
playing for years and I'd love everybody
to read up on the final night we're
moving I'm moving to La my brother's
moving uh to LA and um my parents moving
to Florida so the house is empty we
lived there for 10 12 years and uh
nothing's in the house it's like we're
all leaving the next morning the only
thing out and this is like a movie I
swear but the basketball no one had ever
gone to 50 ever my dad hit the 40s
maybe five or six times got the 30s with
like what I would say is like startling
regularity like almost like 30 32 33 it
was just a regular like Sunday night for
my dad which is ridiculous because I
couldn't get like seven or eight but my
brother would get a couple and win and
so last night we're like all right we'll
go we decided you always decide who
would go first we ever had a random
order and my dad steps up
and just goes
and goes and the piece I really build it
up like I won't draw it out but like he
goes and goes and goes and he gets like
we're all sitting there thinking and we
were we weren't idly sitting there
watching him like we're doing all the
little kid [__]
like I'm whipping it at his chest so he
has to like hurts like my brothers you
know like used to put a hex on the ball
like throw it like 30 feet in the air so
like if you're on the foul line you had
to like move over the kitchen of course
whenever to break what a rhythm and all
of a sudden he's like 33 5 40 42 and all
of a sudden we're just like no one's
talking it is just like dribble swish
dribble Swish and then my brother are
looking at each other no one's saying
like like a pitcher in a perfect game
yeah hits 50. and he stops and where my
brother of course being who he is like
you got to keep going and I'm like what
do you mean he got 50 he's like I hear
51.
I'm like no one's ever come close to my
dad's like he's right and he went and I
think he was 66 or 67 but it was the
most it was the last night in the house
most magical moment I've ever had in my
whole life of sports and like I get
tingles thinking about it made it best
American Sports writing it was like an
honorary mention in the book and like
every year I post on a Father's day and
every year because this influx of people
reading yeah whatever game they played
on the driveway and my brother hit like
10 or 12 in a row I hit like seven rates
so no we didn't come close but it was
just like last night after all the years
he kind of called it slang like the
driveway Dragon like it was amazing so
thank you for bringing that up because
it's probably one of my favorite stories
of all time you ever watched the movie
uh basketball yes right so like that's
the that's the movie I think of when
you're playing driveway basketball with
your brothers of like all the [__]
talking all the things that you can do
to distract them and like all this stuff
for those who haven't watched this this
ridiculous game we literally recreated
uh playing that game like you know you
hit a shot it's like a single a double
triple like whatever we're just
inventing stuff yeah but like if you
recreate the game that means that it
opens up the complete approval to talk
as much [__] as possible to each other
and uh
I remember literally more fights from
that stuff than like anything else so to
not only have your dad hit 50. yeah but
to do it while you guys are talking [__]
like no layups no easy games nothing
right I remember like we would do that
my dad you know he was older he had like
a tricky back like we would walk up and
place the ball like one foot in front of
his feet on the ground and walk away so
like total dick move for like an older
guy with a tricky back so he has to step
off the line he has to move his foot
position he has to pick up the ball and
then it was just like boom boom boom
just a machine I love it was he was he
uh did he appreciate the moment it was
like it was like the natural and I'm
saying it in the clearest sense that's
what whatever that would have felt like
in real life if it happened when Hobbs
at this like the ball hit the ground and
it like Snapped us out of a trance
because he hadn't moved in like 15
minutes it was like he was just there
and we all looked at each other and we
had to do our turns and then we just sat
like I remember sitting there our old
house had like Steps going into like the
front store the front the sides they had
a side door in the house by the driveway
and we just sat and it was like this
weight was just that you could feel the
moment I'm looking at the sky I'm like
I'm gonna like there's no cell phones so
you couldn't just take a picture of the
three of us after the moment like but I
could in my head like I know exactly
what that moment felt like I remember it
clearly I could picture the ball the
hoop like the square was gone it was so
faded like it tilted a little to the
left I remember every Nuance of that and
of that night and then I did the piece
um it was I think we were trying to
think the anniversary of it but I did it
for Father's Day for my like you know
what do you get my dad every dad has
what they need for most part and I
published and tell them and I asked my
mom on the side like you have pictures
of us playing basketball I know we don't
have any from that night and so I got it
and got this this cool blog that used to
compete with Grantland for Yahoo sports
it was called the post game I used to
write for and I was like I want to use
5j piece for my dad and they were like
oh yeah sure I'd already written a bunch
for them and so we posted and all I did
was just send the link and like the
Water Works and he shared it with it
actually went I don't know viral is the
word but like amongst people who cared
about this stuff yeah like it just got
picked up and it was this little goofy
story that got into this like the best
American Sports Anthology which is about
the whole piece but like a mention of it
and it's just one of those things that
I'm so glad I wrote forever and now as
you bring It Up full circle a month ago
like we're playing now with our kids and
it's just hopefully it's a through line
that for you know hundreds of years
Finkels are battling into 50. your kids
are going to be like I gotta win yeah
yeah and then and when they do they'll
have legitimately beat us like if your
dad has the Flex factory you have to
care about winning my son's version will
come in he'll like just show up one day
and bench like 325 and be like what
it's easy just sit down and just press
it yeah totally dead you just all you
have to do is take the weight and just
put it off your chest
any promise
I do not want to have smart ass kids
that's the best dude it actually is
great because like you just might you
know when you you know your wife my wife
didn't like like it's just seeing go
through like I know
I know everything he's thinking like
it's not the modern version but you just
know what's going through his head
because it all went through your head
you know what he thinks is funny like he
just says balls all the time now because
it's funny and I remember it I remember
like being yelled at like stop saying
balls like why it's funny because it is
funny a kid just like what are you doing
balls that's funny I don't know I don't
tell you but like
I think I appreciate that stuff so much
more now as to like the kids who were
doing all that stuff like basically end
up one of two ways like they end up
really successful and like they work
hard they like figure it out whatever
and then obviously there's some that
kind of you know end up in jail or
whatever but like there's very much this
like okay you are not going to end up as
like the mid-level manager of an
accounting firm at like you know middle
of nowhere uh Kansas yeah like you are
going to get one of the extreme there's
a creativity of element that that my son
has and my daughter had my daughter like
she like displays like her abilities
more she's a very like caring person I
can see her being a vet or something
along those lines like who knows but my
son is like got that creative thing that
like you see in people when you look
back on what they're going to come up
with of like entrepreneur or whatever
like he just makes up stuff which is
what I did all the time like he has his
own exit like when he leaves for school
but WWF you picture like whatever the
guys say he'll say like he goes he goes
I brush my teeth I comb my hair and I'm
gonna walk out the door like I don't
care and he goes
dude it's the coolest thing ever like
wouldn't you if you were 12. yeah where
did you learn that yeah let's keep up
with it I uh uh my wife and I have
talked about what's the number one thing
we want to teach our daughter and it's
decision making but the second thing
kind of like uh like a 1A to Me Maybe is
um some people would call it negotiating
I think of it as like the [__]
ability right like the [__] talking
ability because if you're able to do
that I've always thought that like
that's basically what you do all day
long right and the people that I see get
the most stuff done whether they are
negotiating with uh people they work
with whether it's people they run into
in life whether it's uh business like
just all throughout their entire day
they're bullshitting right and not in
like a negative connotation where
they're like making stuff up lying like
whatever but just like it's like this
like street level version of negotiating
yeah that ends up getting you stuff and
I think like a lot of it is if you're
you know if you're doing that walking to
school like you probably are doing some
stuff at school yeah you're negotiating
in the cafeteria too he's a kid who's
gonna like bring the like kind bars from
home and sell them at lunch or something
100 we have a he has a super super drink
snack stand that we set up by the
basketball court in the Summers and make
money like he just has that thought I I
think what you said is 100 true there's
you know you sit around in the in the
world of writing like you'll sit around
a magazine writing session room and you
look around when you're in your 20s like
I wonder is he gonna write the movie he
said he was going to write is this guy
going to run the magazine or start the
thing that they're going to start and so
much of the things that end up happening
are just because you just talked about
it and talked to the people about
wanting to do it I remember talking
about wanting to do my first book and I
was just like looking for an athlete
like that had a moment that I had some
relationship with that I could reach out
legitimately and say you know I always
when I Mentor a lot of younger writers
like do something small with someone and
do a great job especially in writing or
anything creative but probably in any
field and then hit him like if they're
happy with it buy your time set up we
did this this was great here's how we
can take it to the next level and here's
why I think it would be good for both of
us and that was me I did a piece on like
helping guys get their vertical up with
Nate Robinson and it was great we
happened to talk on the phone we got
along called up again when the article
came out did well it just happened to be
that spring when some people remember it
but like for about a month he was like
the most talked about guy in basketball
like he out dueled LeBron and the heat
he was playing in the the uh the the uh
the uh what's called the Bulls loss
Derrick Rose and he was the guy and he
was going like 24 in the fourth quarter
had two comeback wins against the Nets
and it was amazing and then they got
eliminated because you know ultimately
they weren't that good but about I
emailed him after congratulate him on
the Run emailed his agent like hey this
you know this was great we should
capitalize and then I put the article
together with I still have the email of
like you know there's not many guys that
have won three dunk contests that that
have played football in college that are
five eight that played for the Knicks
that that did what you just did like
this is a great culmination to like a
real success story I'd love to write the
book
and you know if you don't have that
ability to have that conversation and
know how to place it to think creatively
of how can I take something that will be
a win for him because he talked about
you'd always want to write a book it was
like a dream thing for him and I would
want to write books in general and I
thought of other athletes but it was
just the perfect situation and we did it
and so when I think of my son and how he
just thinks of these things I can see
him on some level and my daughter two in
different aspects of like there's an
angle there and I'm not just going to
think about I'm going to talk to the guy
who's doing it and figure out a way for
me you have to be crazy enough to think
that you could actually do it like you
like you thought that he may say yes so
you asked yeah I didn't know I mean he
did it we talked on the phone and and
the reason I thought he'd say yes was
because like when you when I do those
emails and anyone listening trying to
pitch things I think the key is to like
start off with why be awesome for them
like a lot of people don't even know I
started the email like do you know about
80 of Nate Robinson's fans have no idea
he was Mr basketball and Mr Football I
bet you 80 90 of the people have no idea
that he could have played a USC on the
championship team with Matt Leinart
Lindale white and Reggie Bush but chose
to stay home because he wanted to help
build a program like no one knows this
stuff and I think they should know that
he's not just some short guy who's got
crazy hops but here's all the things
that he did and I'd love to help him
tell the story because I enjoyed working
with him so much on the basketball piece
that is the most airtight pitch you can
give anybody for anything yeah right and
if you can do that in any field but it
works for books especially well they can
picture it yeah no one does know that
ninety percent of people in the fans who
see me in the basketball court don't
know these things and it's my job to let
them know these things about me and a
book is perfect for that yeah and so
that's how that came about and it's all
from that ability to think and talk a
little bit different than other people
stand out yeah that's it where can we
send people to get the books uh my
website is John finkel.com John
underscore Finkel on Twitter is where I
post about everything I do a lot of I
have a lot of pictures from a lot of
stuff I have Batista put me in a
headlock from all my muscle and fitness
stuff that I used to do and like all the
you know book signings I do put a lot of
stuff out there and you know if you're
into macho man that's the big one I'm
working on now and I put updates there
too and hey go on there and sign up for
books and biceps it is like every single
person who likes uh you know has a
friend who works out but also reads
that's me that's your Guy books and
biceps is very good I highly suggest
people uh sign up for that and then when
is uh matcha book coming out the Macho
comes out next spring actually we're uh
about halfway through getting the
writing done so there's a few people
wait a whole year for this I'm gonna
wait a whole year I'll come back I'll
bring the book we'll jump off the top
ropes and we'll talk about it awesome
well listen thank you so much for taking
the time to do this I really enjoyed it
we'll definitely do it again in the
future yeah man thanks for having me